[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday June 18th
the day of my last video from New York
I'll miss a lot of things about New York
I'll miss its nannies its rich kids it's
funny dogs
I'll miss its funny cats I'll miss its
excellent public transportation system
it's astonishingly low crime rate I'll
miss the everything now just this place
I'll miss its hustle and I'll miss my
friends and I'll also miss this walk
[Music]
King Saul fell on his sword when it all
went wrong
Josef's brothers sold him down the river
for a song and sonny liston rubbed some
tiger balm into his glove some things
you do for money and some you do for
love love
[Music]
Raskolnikov felt sick but he couldn't
say why he saw his face reflected in his
victims twinkling eye some things you'll
do for money and some you'll do for fun
but the things you do for love are gonna
come back to you won by love love is
gonna lead you by the hand
[Music]
into a fight and Sounders play
now we see things as in a mirror dimly
then we shall see each other face to
face way out in Seattle
young Kurt Cobain snuck out to the
greenhouse put a bullet in his brain
snakes in the grass beneath our feet
rain in the clouds above some moments
last forever but some flare out with
[Music]
you